yeah i i mean i'm like talking about
watching yeah yeah
i'm talking about like watching him
sleep um and just like the chat going
crazy and stuff like that
i i watch it and i'm like weirdly
engrossed not because he's sleeping just
because of like the reaction itself
like how active this chat is right and
i'm just like
man this is this is literally just the
truman show we are we are watching the
truman show happen to watch
but he can't leave his room at least in
the truman show you could walk around
yeah yeah yeah that's true but i mean
this is
this is kind of like the closest we've
had to the truman show and it's it would
drive me into this
it's a [ __ ] black mirror episode it
is [ __ ] i mean
it's fascinating yeah but it's also like
i just find it really weird that
i i don't know what the mentality of
people is where like
you watch this dude sleeping on stream
and then you think to yourself
i'mma drop 100 subs while he's asleep
so yeah because like normally you know
i'd like to think if i dropped 100 subs
i would want him to be like
yo thanks for the 100 like at least a
tiny bit of recognition from the person
who i'm sobbing into right yeah yeah but
it's just like
he's not gonna see this at all i'm i'm
gonna just drop 500 bucks just like that
just because i can it's like i don't
know i don't know what the mentality of
it is because like i've given
i don't think anyone does at this point
right because like i've gifted subs
before on stream
right on like other people's chats or
whatever but like
you know dropping a hundred subs on a
dude who's [ __ ] asleep
it's like what do you like what goes
through your head to be like yeah
i'm gonna do that i mean i i think it's
just being part of like this
experience right yeah i i feel like this
is you you feel like the the thing about
twitch that you know
i kind of understand is like you do feel
like you're being a part of something
bigger than yourself right
and i feel like especially like
obviously he didn't
he didn't think he would be this
successful that it was a [ __ ] genius
move
absolutely i was like one day and he
made like 150
000 or something so even even just like
i know
he doesn't seem like the kind of guy who
gives a [ __ ] about the money yeah yeah
yeah
but i mean yeah
yeah but but there's also a part of me
where it's like
i just threw away my humanity for 150
000 dollars right it's like
[ __ ] sign me the [ __ ] up are you
kidding me
[Laughter]
bro film every part of my life for 150
000. i will [ __ ] myself for 150 thousand
dollars
i will poop myself on stream for 100
billion
[Laughter]
look out for one of us [ __ ] fighting
live on twitch
jesus christ i just thought of like the
most cursed content i can think of
what you just love people in the room
and just see who shits themselves first
you say they can't go to the toilet
that's that's the beast
right last person to [ __ ] themselves
wins a million dollars
it's like survivor just with jimmy i
just gave you a fantastic idea bro
you don't have to give me credit for
that
oh my god where do we go from here
i don't know like i don't know i just
find it i just find it fascinating where
it's like you know
you see a content creator like
lightweight on twitch where he's just
[ __ ]
you know doing something that is not
exactly the most
unique thing but it's also that one
thing where it's like well i wouldn't
[ __ ] do it so obviously no one's
gonna do it
yeah right but i'm just like when it
gets to this point of like yeah i've
been streaming for two weeks straight
like
can it go up from there like what what
is what's gonna be the next thing
because everyone's gonna be waiting for
the next subathon right yeah yeah i'm
just saying
and it's just gonna be even longer right
yeah yeah now please now yeah and
like let's like i don't think there will
be a subathon that'll be as
popular as this because he was the first
one who did it and unless he does it
again
i mean even if he does it again i feel
like the hype wouldn't be as
big because it's it's unless no i don't
know i'm
you know listen like unless it
prematurely fizzles out
yeah right where it's like i don't know
i didn't even know when this one's going
to end yet
right so who who the [ __ ] knows i mean
it's it's kind of like
drama twitch plays pokemon oh yeah yeah
i was i was actually about to say right
yeah because like
the last time i saw this phenomenon was
during twitch plays
yeah that's that's the kind of [ __ ] i'm
gonna be telling my kids about right
like honestly i enjoyed the twitch place
pokemon experience so
[ __ ] happy son remember that time
when twitch played pokemon
no like but like the one week thing is
like
it's like twitch plays pokemon but
instead of an algorithm that's just
reading the chat it's literally just a
dude
reading everything in the chat being
like okay left down
up so so to explain twitch plays pokemon
like this was
how many years ago now oh
six years ago where someone made like
someone
like an australian dude actually i was
in australia so basically someone made
um a program that would allow the twitch
chat
to play a full game of pokemon right so
i think it was pokemon red
yes that was played and basically the
chat could put in their inputs
and whatever yeah and whatever inputs
were put in would be inputted into this
emulator
that would be played live in front of
you so if you typed in left in chat and
then yeah
entered it then the program would in
order go
left but the trick is there was
literally what like
fifty thousand hundred thousand plus
people yeah watching this watching and
chatting
and chatting so it's like it's like
giving the game boy to 100
000 people at once being like finish
this game yeah and it's one of the few
times where the word social experiment
actually meant social experiment right
it reminds me of
i saw a clip the other day i was like if
the moon landing happened with twitch
chat
and then they were like literally just
put like an overlay and it's like pog
it's such a good video and i imagine how
much more hype would the moon landing be
with a bunch of pogba oh dude i would
absolutely be playing